there are a lot of weddings that were
red white and true
starting with Ashton and Mila we're
still in love like it's a you hi fight
when you still like each other needs to
like to [ __ ] at the end of the night
after four years of wedded bliss how do
a shin and Mila make it work they have
fun it's actually when the tabloids say
the marriage is over I felt obligated
you felt suffocated by me oh I was just
so overbearing wasn't it yep these two
have always had a sense of humor I'm
Ashton Kutcher that's me and they met on
That 70's Show 21 years ago now their
parents did two young kids that was
pretty relaxed with the first and so the
second one's really fully I mean it's
one of those I'm like where is he it
will be 17 years for Julia Roberts in
sedima tog refer Danny Motor whom she
calls her favorite human this couple's
secret a low-key life or their three
children
plus they vowed to always have each
other's backs there were times I think
that we would look at each other and
think okay if you're here for me I'm
here for you and we'll go just a little
more
[Music]
July 5th marks five years for Jessica
Simpson and Eric Johnson and they're now
family of five from these racy Fifty
Shades of Johnson picks they posted in
2015 to him supporting Jess through her
super tough pregnancy these two are all
about commitment and keeping things uh
sexy you said you love to practice yeah
we definitely we always love to practice
and we actually weren't practicing very
much that much so I don't understand we
keep trying to like this might be a
miracle and you gotta love this epic
throwback to Sharon and Ozzy's Hawaiian
I Do's in 1982 how did these two survive
the rockers infidelity and battle with
addiction well one word the bottom line
is is that I love him he loves me
[Music]